hey guys it's justine and today we're
going to be unboxing all three colors of
the oppo find n phone now i had so much
fun checking out their find x5 pro that
apple also partnered with me to showcase
these phones for you and why this is
really exciting is because actually
these devices are only available to
purchase in china so this is not
something that i normally would be able
to test out time to unbox spoiler um so
i only have two that need to be unboxed
because one of them is actually already
open because i wanted to check it out
but this is the purple one and i haven't
seen the other two yet because they're
still in the box but this holographic
purple is
oh my god it's so beautiful look at this
look at this look at this
so
pretty in the feel like it's honestly
this is like the perfect size phone like
i love
my oh my god that's not so huge in
comparison this is the
pro max but like here's the thing when i
open this up i mean technically it seems
like it would it's
interesting so obviously foldable
devices like that's not something that's
new and i think samsung has really been
leading that charge but i think this is
an incredible contender in that market
and it's kind of cool to see something
that's not actually available here like
this is something that can be in our
future i really like the size the form
factor of it because the fold is much
taller but it's skinnier and then the
flip is about the same size but as a
square so this is kind of like something
that's sort of right in the middle of
both of those devices i kind of think
this might be the perfect size phone
like this is whoa whoa whoa
anyway i haven't even unboxed them and
i'm already talking about it but like
something about this there's something
there so you saw the purple let's do the
unboxing oh whoa look at that oh look at
this nice presentation like it just like
pops right up don't know what that says
so if someone would like translate for
me and i would appreciate it i really
like this packaging
oh
oh i don't understand anything that this
says
so this looks like it's the white
version
god this design like even on the find x5
like i don't know what to call it it
looks like a little snow bank you could
just like ski down it i like that it's
so seamless i really like this hinge
this feels great
wow wow wow okay so there it is
there's the white and of course we have
our well it's our it's the front of the
phone
but then
here we have the inside okay so we've
got two phones so far this purple is
awesome it's so sleek do anything else
in here
oh yes we do
charger i like how cute this is look
they like basically like boxed it in
like a perfect box like i don't honestly
probably was completely unnecessary to
put this in a box like you could have
just been like
there you go we've got some paperwork
okay i understand that we'll just put
that back we've got our cable here so
now it's time for the black version here
we go
same box same look
here it is
oh
wow
so this is actually very nice so in
person it kind of looks like it has a
slight little blue like a midnight color
it seems like it's definitely a really
nice matte look at that this is so
beautiful i can't believe how nice these
phones are like i honestly wasn't even
sure what to expect because i have not
reviewed very many apple phones before
so i am honestly pleasantly surprised
with the quality and i really love just
this seamless camera bump like they
really did a great job with that it
looks pretty great i am definitely into
it so these are all now unboxed
which means let's take a closer look
[Music]
these are running a qualcomm snapdragon
888 with 12 gigs of ram and up to 512
gigs of storage with a 4500 milliamp
battery life it has a side fingerprint
scanner inside the power button and of
course the main highlight of this phone
is the fact that it's foldable this
hinge has 136 components that will give
you a super smooth fold this is also
allowing for a wider center fold so that
there'll be less screen creasing and
gaps between the display when folding
speaking of displays this is their
custom 12 layer serene display for
durability and flexibility when folding
it has this really super thin layer of
ultra thin glass with the ability to be
folded over 200 000 times while keeping
its smooth feel and no crease the screen
inside is an ltpo display with smart
dynamic refresh rate that adjusts from 1
to 120 hertz depending upon what you're
doing one of the things that i really
like about this design is how flexible
the hinge allows you to be with this
device it will kind of let you use it as
a tripod for various shooting scenarios
now as a content creator this is
something that i absolutely love because
you never really know kind of what
you're going to be doing when you're out
and about shooting so the fact that i
could just set this down anywhere and
set it at a specific angle that i want
is pretty awesome another cool thing is
that when the angle is below 60 degrees
the screen automatically will move the
image preview to the bottom to make it
easier to set up your shot you can see
that this would be pretty great for some
sky time lapses and those camera
controls move lower on the screen for
easier access i absolutely love taking
time lapse videos so this is definitely
something that i could see myself using
this for now this is a nice 90 degree
work mode for email chatting or even
just watching content but one of the
things i love is you can just open up
the display to get a full screen
experience i'm definitely incredibly
interested in the tech of this and it's
kind of showing us what the future has
in store for us as far as foldable
devices and the possibilities there's a
new split camera feature that will let
you use the inner display to take photos
on one side and then you can view share
or even delete the most recent ones that
you took on the other we love a
multi-tasking queen now if you're taking
a photo from the main camera with a
display unfolded you can use both the
inner and outer display for both you and
whoever you're taking the photo for i
mean there's been so many times where
i've made my sister take photos let me
see let me see let me see we're gonna
take another but if she's taking it and
i can kind of pose and get myself set
and ready i think that'll save us all a
lot of time we all know that the cameras
on the backs of the phones are usually
so much better but with this foldable
design you can still preview your
content even when it's taken with the
cameras on the back this does have a
triple camera setup with the usual
suspects our wide ultra wide and
telephoto and as far as video is
concerned you can shoot 4k 30 and 60.
the selfie camera is a wide angle 32
megapixel camera and it will record
1080p 30 frames a second video i
have no idea what i just clicked on
and uh
i think i'm shopping i'm interested
either way this is kind of a cool
demonstration of how the dual screens
are kind of working even though this is
one full screen so like i'm browsing
over here
shopping over here i don't know if i
should continue clicking things because
i might start shopping by accident i may
accidentally enter my credit card and i
don't know i should not be clicking
around okay let's check out a couple
more apps
what's this
don't know what i'm doing
this looks like we might be listening to
music
audiobooks it's an audiobook
that's a song it's okay okay so maybe
maybe it is music
[Music]
you just go to my front screen yes he
went to the front screen
oh man okay so i just took a selfie and
i was like wait that's not actually what
i would look like there's some
retouching filters on okay so i'm gonna
turn the skin textures all the way up
cheeks i can change my cheekbones i can
change my eye size i can change my nose
i can change my chin wait i can change
my entire head i've turned into a
character
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching i
hope you guys enjoyed this video i
really had a great time checking out
this device i'm so into foldable phones
and honestly like the form factor of
this phone i really do hope that they
bring something like this to the us
because honestly like i can't really
just keep it for the form factor it's
like the perfect phone size and the
screen display like once it's unfolded
it's it's honestly like perfect
oh i'm so into it
anyway if you guys want to subscribe to
my channel be sure to hit subscribe if
you aren't already and of course hit the
bells to be notified when i post new
videos and i would love to hear from you
guys in the comments below let me know
what you guys think of these devices and
is this something that you would look
forward to checking out if it was here
in the us and some of you guys are
international so you might not even be
in the states you may be somewhere else
so wherever you are is this something
you might be into i'll see you guys in
the next video bye
[Music]